the place came to my work
yeah
they have footage of me with Chloe Lake
they have footage of the two of us
together I'm fully in
no matter what
what about you
are you in or out
hey hi hey is uh is Nate okay he seemed
kind of down last night uh yeah no he's
he's fine he's I think last night he had
a little too much bread I love him you
know that he's one of my oldest friends
but
last few years he's gonna kind of shut
himself off we hardly talks to any of us
yeah he just kind of keeps a lot inside
but he's
he's good we're he's good we're good
okay thank you
I do need to talk to you about one other
thing
um
I'm sorry
but I have to take you off Palisades
what no no no no I need that listing the
owners want you offer they're taking it
elsewhere okay the price tag is way too
high I've been telling them maybe but
had it for six weeks
and it didn't move
do you have anything else in the
pipeline yeah of course always I am in
fact I met a buyer last week at
Palisades and he just put in a big cash
offer on Avondale that's old what they
accepted an offer this morning some
family from out of state
okay well this this my guy's very
motivated and I have more options to
show him okay great
but in the meanwhile why don't you go
back to the apartment space the
apartments you're so good in that world
[Music]
you're definitely not going to eat that
may I
there you go so thank you so much
I love your shoes
so uh who you told about your allegation
no one
Ava no one why would they Ava doesn't
know nobody knows
how'd you come up with it I mean it's
pretty crazy
really you want me to go through it yeah
the blood the scratches you follow the
girl out of the bar
still I mean it's kind of a leap
like the girl you killed the Pomona
I looked it up
I bet you there's a [__] ton of
forensics all over the West Side River
Murders that lead to you so we could
pretend this isn't happening but it's
happening
and we need to deal with it
you came up with all of this by yourself
are you in or out
I'm not asking again
all right buddy
I'm gonna give you some advice because I
really like you and because
you have to make friends in L.A right
I would strongly urge you
to drop this
because Nathan
this
will not end well for you
Maybe not today maybe not tomorrow
but eventually
I guarantee
yeah
there's a lot of easier ways to save
your shitty marriage my friend
you're a [__] monster
I'm the monster [__] you no long Domino
lasted in County I give you six months
[__]
why don't you sit down Nathan
all right
I'm in
on one condition
you and I still throw
excuse me what
there's a reason
[Music]
why I'm feeling so high I must be the
season
when that love light shines all around
us